I hooked up with the rapper I hooked up
with an actor I hooked up with a rapper
I hooked up with a rapper I hooked up
with an athlete I hooked up with a
rapper
um this Canadian rapper was coming to a
club in my city I pulled up they took my
weed at the door so throughout the night
I like see him and his friends are like
smoking up so I walk by they make eye
contact they tell me to come around I go
around We Vibe all night smoke all night
and the rest is history alrighty nice
okay I can't name draw it's Canadian
rapper though
all right okay
what's your story my story okay so I met
this rapper through a mutual friend so
then I went to his crib and then he gave
me his number and then we just kept
talking back and forth and then he'd be
like come over come over and I was like
okay and then my homegirls came over and
then he was like I'm gonna go on tour
like you want to come with me so like we
all went with him we were there for like
[__] weeks and then we all went to
Vegas together and then like I don't
know yeah we were just
yeah you know what happened
really mine was Soulja Boy
okay so I just started working at a
talent agency and my co-worker invited
me to this actor's party barely knew who
he was but we bonded because he's from
North Carolina and I'm also from North
Carolina and you know
things happened
and I'm not gonna name drop you're
mixing business with pleasure always
always
my friend invited me to a kickback at
the Ritz
and there was like a bunch of basketball
players there one of them liked me but I
didn't know who he was but I was like
whatever I'm just gonna like go with it
and then we started texting we hung out
and then we hooked up
and his name was Melo ball
I don't know much about sports but I'm
like okay
so I went to a nightclub in West
Hollywood with a couple of my
girlfriends and they knew like one of
the promoters that was there and they
were all like oh we're having an after
party at this house and like the hills
whatever you guys should come it was
like this big ass house that had like a
recording studio in the back and he was
supposed to be recording an album with
Halsey or maybe like a single or
something like at the time and then we
ended up just kind of like vibing like
hanging out the whole night and yeah and
then things happened and can you say
that's where it was post Malone but this
is like a long time ago so he was like
in his like coming up era so
different but okay okay I am a legal sex
worker and it was my boss's birthday
party and my celebrity was one of the
performers at the party so he's up there
on stage he's doing his thing he's
singing and he pulls out a block and
he's like anybody got a lighter and I'm
like uh me hi so I pull out the lighter
out of my bag handed to him and then we
smoke we party we hang out we're vibing
and we get back into the limousine and I
go back with him to his realm and well
as everyone has said things happen I
just think her story is too rehearsed
there was too many details bro it's like
20 23 like who the [__] is rides in a
limousine I need to know if this is like
your tactic if your tactic is just like
oversell the story because I feel like
too many details because I was sass of
you because there was too little details
yeah
well I can say he was very very lovely
in bed that's for sure he had a really
big
really big and I'll be real forward
definitely larger than average Magnum
size I know because I had to go and get
one because he didn't have any in his
room I want to hear more about your
story yeah okay yeah did you know him
when you like met him like did you
recognize him barely his show had like
just come out okay
yeah I familiar face but I I was it a
reality show or like a movie it's a TV
show like a drama series right well was
he good to you in bed oh yes it will
bless you it wasn't easy do you remember
it or not what was his genre like actor
single actor he's an actor he's on a
Netflix show okay recent yes what's his
ethnicity what what was he wearing
bathing suit because we were in the hot
tub did you guys like make out in the
hot tub a little bit did he use a condom
never I'm just kidding
but I want to know why you have been so
quiet over here what do you have going
on you're just standing here how long
did it last
um
like five minutes not that long did you
sign any oh no you didn't not his name
he wanted we decided NDA like a year
later but I just didn't so oh so here
who here did sign an NDA did anybody
anyone sign an ndi yeah it was like
early enough on in his career I feel
like no one even like cared oh
oh
hi are you enjoying this episode of odd
one out comment down below who you think
the mole is And subscribe for more
episodes of odd one out let's get back
into the video
[Music]
bye sorry
I think they voted me off because my
story was just too good so how did you
meet the person again at the club is he
like an A-list celebrity he's like he's
b-list okay it's like good enough like I
would know who it is yeah okay would you
do it again is he on the radio
um yeah he literally texts me all the
time
what race is he
um he's Middle Eastern she looks away
every single time we ask her question
she looks in different directions
I'm a really big
even if I'm lying like I'll be like this
so you every single time we ask a
question you look in a different
direction she plays with her hair yeah
um what about you
what about did he do anymore Netflix
shows after that this show is still
amazing
I'm like should we watch it
you should watch it what is it called
it's too obvious I guess I don't want to
say how big was it
I don't know
I like to call it the Goldilocks because
it was just right it was like boyfriend
yeah
like August
no no this was recent yeah but he wasn't
known but he has two seasons but he
wasn't known two seasons in one year
I don't know about that
no he was he's known but it's the first
season does he have any other shows
besides the Netflix show I I don't think
so ready to hook up on a scale from one
to ten I would rate my hookup
and eight because I would like a longer
period of sexual intercourse
I don't know the experience was like at
nine a I don't know it kind of got
sheisty what got trusty about it nothing
it was just like there's too many people
and we already hooked up with your
friends no he didn't oh that's nice
what about you um I would give it like a
seven because I was drunk and probably
wouldn't do it again and it was the
Goldie
that doesn't mean there are other ones I
would rate mine a five because it was
too big and it was too fast and it was
not good
it's like they don't know how to use it
because I think just like having a big
is enough and it's like actually so not
true
so bad and it's like literally the worst
it's not the size of the wave it's the
motion of the ocean it is 100 I feel
like this sounds Shady because it's not
about him at all but I would give it
like a four but just because it was like
a lot of drinking and smoking and stuff
was involved so it was like we had some
issues like getting there if that makes
sense and then like I think we just gave
up after like a certain amount of time
and I was just like yeah like it's all
good it wasn't his best performance no
no I'm sure he's great but I wouldn't
know though so I don't know we just
haven't talked to you guys that much
this round so what team does he play for
yeah uh I don't know I don't know about
sports like I didn't even know who he
was when he was like trying to get my
number what team does he play for I
don't know oh okay heard we need some
post Malone questions for her yeah yeah
even though we believe her but who knows
people when I'm lying I stare in here
[Applause]
like I'ma look you down like it's all
good did you do it again did I already
ask you that I probably wouldn't one
because I think he's like wifed up with
a baby now
yeah I'm pretty sure he has like a baby
mama now and they move to Utah
foreign
[Music]
she won't make eye contact with you when
she's playing with her hair and looking
around
the guy she hooked up with had two
seasons of whatever Show on Netflix it
just wasn't adding up
sorry
raise your hand on three okay one two
three
I feel like we got them all out I still
don't believe you let's be like real
about it so like who are we like feeling
collectively
I feel like you yeah that's what I'm
hearing too because I don't know Middle
Eastern Canadian rapper but like there's
like
okay okay no shade no yeah no shade no
love your music
thanks for smoking with me
what about the NBA Ritz Carlton were
they playing a game that day in L.A I
don't know like I didn't even make this
whole team or was it just him no it was
him and his brothers and then like their
friends like two or three friends just
his brothers play in the NBA yeah both
of them are they the ones at the
Facebook show yeah okay okay
do you feel like like I said earlier
with like Alice I was like you could be
telling the same story like we could
have all hung out with these celebrities
yeah
[Applause]
I was like all right
how did you guys meet like I said I was
at a nightclub in West Hollywood so the
promoter he knew post Malone's manager
somehow and they like wanted to get a
bunch of like hot girls to like the
Mansion when they were recording yeah
like what if it's one of the people we
kicked out already
I mean
um I'm like I don't know whether to
trust all of you or all of you are lying
to me because if you one of his [__]
lines
I feel like it's there's still something
going on one because you keep on pushing
to end the round and then maybe she
wants to be in here
us three old name jobs I know I've name
dropped in other situations on a podcast
and then I ruined that relationship
podcast what happens
foreign
[Music]
into the part a little bit too much like
the way she came dressed like the way
she was acting she kept on trying to end
the game
she's saying like such a typical party
story that she could have just partied
and went to the studio but like not
actually done anything with the rapper
and Avalon
we're showing Hayden you guys lost 30
seconds so you two off the side together
okay
home girls still sucks but she talks too
much it's like she's really confidently
the person being eliminated
I'm sorry I'm sorry
we have beef I thought they were my
friends I thought we were cool there was
an alliance there was a trifecta and I
got booted if you guys think that
there's still a liar among you three you
can continue playing one two three
wait to keep playing right yes
yes the Box turns red the mole has one
and they are still among you three but
the box they're all telling the truth at
the cash prize
[Music]
[Applause]
I knew it
and on three the mole can step forward
one two three
I kind of believed you from the
beginning oh my gosh that was so much
scarier than I thought it was gonna be I
thought I prepared enough but I did not
I do work for a talent agency a lot of
it like you guys were saying was a true
story I just added the hook up but if
you were at the party with this guy yeah
I went with an actor I am from North
Carolina and the actor I chose is from
North Carolina so I thought that would
all check out I did [__] up with the
seasons because that's where I yeah who
was the actor you chose I'll tell you
guys like off camera just because it's
like I mean everything like with the
actor is true I just like mix my story
up a little bit like what we like what
you were saying yeah yeah and you kicked
me out we could have won
wait hold on what's in this
hello
[Laughter]